volle ränge wie sie gerade formuliert
hat darf es natürlich nicht geben wir
müssen wir bei allem was wir machen
verhältnismäßig sein und es muss auch
eine gleichbehandlungsgrundsatz geben
aber wir haben unsere elbphilharmonie
mit zweieinhalb tausend plätzen da haben
wir uns genau angeguckt und haben
überlegt wie kann man mit abstandsregeln
überhaupt wieder live konzerte und
zuschauer in diesem großen konzertsaals
zu lassen
und da sind wir draufgekommen dass 47
750 personen in diesem riesigen
konzertsaal unter wirklich strengen
maßstäben gut auch nochmal wieder live
ein konzert hören können und wenn ich
mir ein fußballstadion mit 50.000 plätze
vorstellen warum soll es nicht möglich
sein wenn man das entsprechende regelt
zuwegung abwägung da ein paar tausend
zuschauer zu schauen zu lassen auch live
das ist eigentlich die idee dass man
sagt das was unter infektionsrisiko
schutz möglich ist das sollte man
möglich machen also hamburg votiert
morgen bei der konferenz der
gesundheitsminister für zuschauer ins
stadion
das wollen wir mal sehen er fängt ja
möglich davon ab wie die konzepte sind
aber ich sage ihnen eins sobald sie mal
irgendwo in einem bereich etwas nicht
fett also nicht nicht wie heißt es und
nach gleichbehandlungs grundsätzen
beurteilen landen sie doch sofort bei
gericht was haben wir alles vor gericht
vertreten müssen weil irgendeine branche
gesagt hat da sind wir aber jetzt anders
behandelt worden als eine andere branche
und das ist auch ein anspruch den wir
haben dass wir nicht ein bereich völlig
locker lassen und alles andere staaten
regulieren und ich kann mir vorstellen
aber das kann ich jetzt hier das hängst
du dich von denen von den einzelnen
stadien und auch von den konzepten ab
ich kann mir vorstellen dass man unter
strengen regelungen auch wieder live
zuschauer im stadion hat